who can provide you with free health
care school expanded Social Security and
a mandated $15 minimum wage without
spending a single dime don't be daft you
know who so I received this flyer at the
Grand Rapids feminist Film Festival and
ironically people who hate social
justice warriors were mad at me for not
supporting Bernie Sanders Clause the bat
disregard the fact that his tacky
campaign slogan was stolen from a late
80s Jane Fonda workout tape many of you
think that I'm wrong in the financial
issues and that's fair even Bernie
Sanders himself uh said that the attacks
on him are unwarranted despite the fact
that he's never really rebutted them so
I'm gonna promise them free health care
and free college but Bernie how do you
have you plan to pay for that it's never
comma so anecdotally this is the promo
material that was sent to me and these
were all the free things proposed
without any real plan to pay for them
other than these two things plus a third
thing that we'll get into now is this
even close to financially viable granted
all mathematical equations available to
human beings right now say no but you
don't have to take my word for it please
allow me a moment to plug our capitalist
sponsors in audible.com this week
there's a promotion going on audible.com
slash Crowder where you can get a free
audio book to try again that's
audible.com slash Crowder it's free
support the show
I recommend Ben Carson's book read by
mr. high-energy himself Benny we're
going to be just fine because she
believed it and if you don't download it
you're probably racist audible.com slash
Crowder again it is a great service
because like the podcast at monied you
listen to an i
or SoundCloud audible you can listen to
a book if you don't have time to read it
and it can be going on in the background
while you're reading researching
studying I use it all the time
audible.com slash Crowder I really do
recommend it and don't be racist get ben
Carson back to Sanders financial experts
have done the math and they have figured
out that Bernie Sanders his plan would
add an additional 18 trillion dollars
for national debt over the next 10 years
I know you'll say it's Wall Street
Journal that's been debunked I'll get to
that as well really quickly here on
YouTube I see some self-professed
financial gurus use national deficit and
debt interchangeably but they're
different and it's important why is that
so the deficit in 2014 meaning the
annual spending beyond our revenue was
500 billion our national debt is around
18 trillion so the deficit is the yearly
overspending and the national debt is
the cumulative the sum total so if we
round the numbers for simplicity at 500
billion in annual deficit in two years
that'll put us at 19 trillion okay okay
so in addition to the current spending
deficit of hundreds of billions the
Bernie Sanders proposal would add an
additional on top of that spending 18
trillion dollars in debt over the next
ten years at minimum so and what does
Bernie Sanders plan to spend this month
well free college free health care
expanded social programs like I said
some of this math came from The Wall
Street Journal and Bernie Clauses
supporters were quick to condemn it as
dishonest and so are the Occupy
Democrats page of the 99% yet his
supporters and Bernie Sanders himself
have yet to offer an official rebuttal
or even explanation for the new spending
instead say that we could potentially
save money in the theoretical but Bernie
someone is bound to ask you trust me
it's never going to end the equation so
the pro Sanders arguments come back to
three main components stopping the
endless military spending taxing the
rich more and finally they claim that a
analyze healthcare plan would actually
save us money now some of you think that
was spending versus revenue math may be
more complex than people lead on to be
maybe so but allow me to start off with
an absolute and extreme to make a point
if you cut the United States military
entirely and taxed all earnings over 1
million dollars at 100 percent you still
couldn't come anywhere close to paying
for this point myself clear the chances
of the media or my voting constituency
asking how I'll pay for this plan is
lower than Ted Cruz having a sex dungeon
okay so let's start with the military
the military industrial complex why is
that phrase thrown around so much
because just like ignorant bumper
stickers it assumes that the United
States biggest expenditure is its
military it's not total military
spending in this country accounts for 18
percent of our budget by the same as
Social Security Medicare Medicaid and
certainly a lot less than all of our
safety programs and welfare initiatives
when combined not even close people love
to throw out the number that the United
States spends more on its military than
anybody but when you account for
percentage of GDP we're just so
successful in America we actually spend
less than Russia Saudi Arabia and Israel
food for thought in the last seven years
year-over-year increased spending in the
military has far outpaced the United
States in many countries like Russia
China Saudi Arabia Turkey etc granted I
know many of you think that's a good
thing and that the United States
military might should be seen as an evil
instead of a virtue so let's just move
on right now to the numbers 2014 total
military spending was around six hundred
and ten billion dollars so let's cut all
of that 100% gone over 10 years we
gained about six trillion dollars
congratulations you've made the United
States and the world a much less safe
place but you're not even close to
paying for all of Bernie Sanders free
stuff from other people's piles of [ __ ]
so we can get more free which brings us
to point DOS multiculturalism
okay so let's tax the wealthy they can
afford it after all the top one maybe
five ten percent didn't earn that
through responsible saving investing in
tireless work so
the moral thing to do to steal their
[ __ ] let's assume so still would it
solve the spending problem firstly when
we throw around terms like top 1% or 10%
it's important that we define them what
constitutes the top 1% in America it's
actually any household with annual
income exceeding $500,000 a great living
to be sure but hardly the vilified
billionaires we've come to believe but
let's start with a number even higher
the top percentage of the top 1% would
it even cover our costs let's say you
text all earnings every dollar one
hundred percent over a million dollars
in this country what would you get about
another six hundred and sixteen billion
dollars annually add that with a six
trillion from entirely cutting the
military and you've got another six
trillion so you're at 12 trillion
dollars yeah it's still six trillion
dollars short
moving along down the trail disregarding
the fact that nobody would work for free
the negative ramifications would be
insane particularly the punishment of
small business other than the fact that
essentially a 100 percent tax is absurd
how else can we generate revenues well
you'd probably have to increase that
number from the top percent of the top
1% to let's say the top 5%
those bastards can still afford it so
what define the top 5% any households
earning a hundred and ninety thousand
dollars annually or more damn I thought
they'd have more well what if we just
take almost everything or ninety percent
like Bernie Sanders seems ok with with
every one of the top 10% top 10% in the
United States as any household earning a
hundred and fifty thousand or more not
exactly the fat cats you thought huh
still for the greater good they can
afford to have more if not nearly all of
their stuff taken right not exactly even
those evil hundred and fifty thousand
heirs are still overburdened paying over
seventy three percent of the taxes
already despite only making up 43
percent of all revenue even if that
sounds fair to you mr. pantsless
YouTuber with a bag of cheetos it still
doesn't make skyrocketing their taxes
any more financially viable
not boxes it's why Greece with their 46%
income taxes well Greece it's why their
own government has a really tough time
collecting taxes it's why the Laffer
curve exists it's why nearly every
single empirical economic study ever
conducted and published in peer-reviewed
academic journals shows a negative
impact between higher taxes and economic
growth so again using the most extreme
examples of entirely cutting the
military and entirely taxing the wealthy
you still don't come close to covering
what we need so when the verifiable
tangible numbers must be thrown out to
make your case that's when leftists
direct you to point free the theoretical
proposal that instituting a nationalized
health care plan could potentially save
us money now even the leftist at Salon
and Huffington Post are not arguing that
the Bernie Sanders national health care
plan is a net gain but that it could
figuratively save us 5 trillion dollars
when compared with the 18 trillion in
expanded spending namely by reducing
administrative costs medical inflation
etc so we've reached the point where you
now just have to take their word for it
the idea is predicated on the notion
that we will spend 5 trillion dollars
nationally anyway so it's in our best
interest to give the consumer buying
power choice and freedom over to the
federal government because it could save
us money in the long run and potentially
increase the quality of health care a
few problems here not the least of which
is a gross infringement on the freedoms
of the American public who still want to
be able to choose their own health care
like I said it's important to note that
we're in the realm of projected costs
now as a general rule the United States
government never comes in anywhere near
their projected costs when taking over
massive social programs like this from
small programs like student loan
forgiveness to larger programs like
Medicaid and yes Social Security itself
what leftist out is a victory with
Obamacare in costs versus initial
projections is really hardly a victory
here because projected costs actually
rose untill surprise the government kept
expanding the deadline and every non
Obamacare enrollee saw their premiums
skyrocket even leftists aren't thrilled
with the results and of acknowledges
that a mandated subsidization of other
people's health care
is not really comfortable to the
projected costs of a nationalized
single-payer health care plan so you
have to point to countries like Canada
where I was raised and you can see a
video here on Canadian healthcare as a
moral victory when Canadian liberals
themself have acknowledged the need for
reform and fixing the $500 pay gap when
it comes to their nationalized health
care plan it's at 500 I meant five
hundred billion I don't want to spend
that much time on this point because the
fact is everybody is guessing it's like
arguing over whether Superman could be
Batman in a fighter Ronda Rousey versus
Floyd Mayweather it's silly it's
unrealistic and a whole lot like Bernie
Sanders
so in closing and I'm getting very near
the end of this now to believe in Bernie
Sanders proposal and tax plan you have
to do the following disregard that
cutting our military entirely wouldn't
make a dent disregard the tax in the
wealthy and even household with one
hundred fifty thousand a year or more
those bastards at an astronomical rate
wouldn't cover it and disregard the fact
that said job creators and wealth
generators would take their wealth and
jobs somewhere else
you must believe that the wealthy will
effectively work for free because they
want to pay for your stuff just that
much
once you ignore all these concrete and
tangible example simply shout that a
nationalized health care plan would save
us money and make up for the trillions
and trillions of dollars and costs
completely unaccounted for
the scariest part there are still
millions of people who actually believe
in it and nothing you or I say can
convince them otherwise because how can
you compete with make-believe
subscribe to this channel otherwise I'll
have to keep doing aerobics